- hey everybody good afternoon
happy podcast it's your host ethan klein
come to you very happy happy and
satisfied and tired your house - ethan
klein here today today's sponsor
sponsors are equip and hims thank you
very much today is a special episode I
popped in just to you know I wanted to
keep everyone updated I want to I want
to tell the story when it's fresh in my
mind and I think it's a beautiful story
and I want to have a tons of pictures of
tons of videos and I want to just talk
about this experience with you guys
ela had the baby obviously he's happy
he's healthy he's beautiful
EAL is a goddess she just absolutely
crushed childbirth her body is like a
transformer you know into like a this
incredible baby yielding body like I got
to be honest with you guys I was worried
that childbirth was gonna be extremely
hard on ela because she's super thin and
she's very petite you know very small
very skinny and so I wasn't sure how she
was get that but that baby out of there
to be frank with you guys
I wasn't sure how a baby was gonna get
out of there
but her but she is a little transformer
her body became this incredible supermom
and it turns out she is not only good at
like her she's like has this ultimate
body that the nurses and the doctors and
everyone was like blown away by how well
she's handled this like for example we
so Ellis went into labor started going
into labor on the 3rd or actually no
started going to labor on the at about
12 a.m. on the 4th theater was born on
the 4th at 9 p.m.
902 p.m. so
she was in labor for wait it was the day
before right you're saying midnight the
night before and then the baby was
delivered at 9:00 p.m. the following day
no no no it was the same day so she was
in labor for for almost 24 hours because
right 10 11 12 so she was in labor for
19 hours yet that makes sense
so she she started having contractions
around 12 o'clock on the 4th and they
didn't go away you know that's how you
know that when you're in labor
when you have non-stop contractions and
they just they don't go away and there's
there's very little frequent or duration
between them so she's like I'm having
contractions non-stop non-stop non-stop
but she was actually she was handling
the pain very well so luckily we were
able to stay home for a long long time
before because they say that you want to
stay at home for as long as possible
before you go to the hospital one reason
being that hospitals often will turn
women away because they're not far long
enough in labor let's say go home and
come back or they'll just make you walk
around the hospital for a long time
until your labor progresses enough and
so we wanted to avoid that and they want
to avoid that so we stayed at home as
long as you can and the rule is that you
know if the pain is manageable and
basically you feel that you can stay at
home long enough then you should so that
went on until about 5:00 a.m. I either
fell asleep okay and while she was in
labor she just drifted off and I was
thinking like alright well I was keeping
an eye on her because I didn't want to
fall asleep but she fell asleep she'd
been asleep for like an hour to him so I
was like maybe it's you know maybe it's
not happening it was fine so I I fall
asleep too
and then around 5:00 a.m. I feel like
scratching on my head I think like oh he
was giving me a header up or something I
was like oh how nice
and I wake up and she's like she's
looking at me she's like
she's like Ethan we gotta go I think I'm
I think I'm I think it's time you know
like [ __ ] that's not a head rub
that's how wake the [ __ ] up you know and
I've been getting a lot of those by the
way in the past 24 hours every time I
wake up now it's like a 10 on the chaos
scale the baby screaming or ela
screaming hap always a 10 on the Cask
out the only time I wake up the only way
I wake up now was like this because you
sleep so deep because I'm so
sleep-deprived I have like three or four
hours of sleep since he was born a night
a day and so now it's like the deepest
sleep imaginable I wait where was I so
she's scratching on my head it's 5:00
a.m. I'm like okay let's do this so I
start gathering our things you know
putting everything together putting it
in the car or getting ready I call my
parents to come get shredder who had a
fantastic time he was had the best time
ever
with his grandparents god bless him and
so we're just chilling I pack everything
up and we're chilling and II was able to
wait until about another two hours till
7 a.m. and she's like all right you know
let's go drive the hospital we get to
you know the the baby and deliveries or
whatever section of the hospital
Kizer by the way we did it with Kaiser
and they were so amazing I have to say
if there's anybody out there who is
expecting or wants to have children I
don't know if Kaiser is a California
thing or a national thing but Kaiser
Permanente is man so good I was happy
with every single aspect of their care
but anyway we get in we check in and
they're basically first they put her in
a room to see how far along she is to
see if they can admit her or not and so
they check her cervix which is like the
opening like all the way up the vagina
and basically you go from 0 to like 10
centimeters is fully dilated
and that's where the kind of the baby
drops down from and so they check it and
she was 6 centimeters when she checked
in which if you know anything about baby
yield year/year ding yielding that's
incredible
that's like she's almost there and for a
first-time birth
that's because first time births can go
like 24 48 36 hours it could just be a
grueling marathon but she came in 6
centimeters which was just incredible
and then there's this other thing about
like a face twitch I guess is I really
don't understand it but it's like
there's some kind of blockage that needs
to soften up and so she was 90% of face
out of a hundred so she was like all the
doctor was like this is your first child
I can't believe it you know I cannot
believe you're at 6 centimeters when you
came in and she was so casual about she
was handling it so gracefully you can
see there's this crazy they put they put
all these plugs on her and one measures
the baby's heartbeat and then one
measures her contractions it's really
cool and you can see it on the screen
you can see her contractions coming in
waves and you can see how like intense
they are so you can kind of see it as
she's feeling it and a pen and they and
these when you're six centimeters
dilated that's like a seven eight you
know nine on the pain scale for most
women and they were like just floored by
how well she was tolerating it she
wasn't screaming she wasn't you know
even complaining she was just silently I
call her a silent suffer because she's
such a champ you know she doesn't
complain she doesn't like to he doesn't
like to complain about anything she's
sitting there you know with these six
centimeter contractions not complaining
not screaming I'm a-gettin noise the
doctors like what is going on with this
superhuman
I said you're silent suffer I'm a I'm a
very loud suffer if I was switched
places with you everybody in this
hospital would know how much pain I'm in
right now I just have a video of I've
got a bunch of videos and pictures and
stuff oh I guess I'm getting to the part
with the first video here so so we're in
that room there's there's two rooms that
we were in the first so anyway they saw
she was super dilated until like oh yeah
you're admitted you're good so we're in
this kind of waiting room which is a
really small room with a bed and a bunch
of machinery but there's only enough
room for like you know me ela and like
two other doctors it's really small so
she's laying down and I've got a little
chair beside her and we were in that
room for from 8 a.m. till 7 p.m. so 11
hours that right yeah yeah 11 hours and
I gotta say like so the doctors came in
and and gave her the epidural about an
hour to N and the epidural is this
really crazy method and it's dude I
cannot endorse this enough I mean it was
just magnificent how much it helped her
but it's like a pain drip that goes
right into your spine and so they bring
in an N enthusiast to say that right
probably so yeah maybe you guys know not
though and they put a long-ass needle in
her frickin spine directly endorse mine
we able to watch them do that no they
they said that they preferred that the
husband takes a walk during that because
they've had husbands like faint before
yeah I know it sounds crazy and done so
I was like you know what I'm gonna go
away and got like they ever was a
cafeteria on the bottom floor I want got
probably one of the worst sandwiches
I've ever had you know they say they
joke about airport food and plane food I
have to tell you hospital food is
probably
the apex of terrible cuisine I have a
picture actually of one of the meals we
got let me pull it up what since I'm on
the topic what do you guys think about
this let me show you this is egg bro why
is there no texture looks good why is
there what with the funk whoa why is
there note what the hell
why is there no texture do you see this
yeah it looks what the hell is that it
looks like a loaf cheese cake like bread
it looks like cheese but it's just egg
but there's no freaking texture to it
it's the weirdest [ __ ] I ever saw that's
sausage on there it shouldn't I don't
know I okay this is weird this how it's
working that's it's is one of the most
disgusting things I ever saw and it
tasted just as bad it looks like marble
there's no texture I never I mean I was
I was impressed and disgusted both
because I have never seen that technique
before yeah it was off it was yeah so
anyway I'll get told all that good stuff
in a second so I took a walk came back
but they gave her the epidural and then
what it does it's actually really cool
because it completely numbs you pretty
much from like the stomach down and
because it plugs into your spine it
doesn't affect the baby it never goes
into your bloodstream so I don't know
why a lot of people like not to get the
epidural and I'm not sure I fully
understand why I think there's a lot of
myths that taking the epidural can make
the labor process take longer heard that
and don't people have fears like you
just said that it'll affect the baby so
even though it doesn't affect it doesn't
it doesn't go in the bloodstream so it
doesn't even go in the baby's body so I
guess the fear is that it can make labor
longer you know I asked my doctor about
that and he said well that's not really
true because the epidural makes you so
much more calm
it pretty much cancels out any delay in
labor that the numbness would cause
because the labor progresses along so
much faster when you're at when you're
calm and relaxed that the baby is able
to drop down and come out but when
you're tense up and you get super
stressed that process that slows down
the process too so he thinks it's a wash
it doesn't really slow it down in his
opinion but regardless I would much much
rather ela be comfortable than and it'd
take longer
you know and and it did because right
before she got the epidural her
contractions were getting more severe
and she was like she was very you know a
an absolute champion about it
but she started from being like kind of
agnostic about it where when the current
when the contractions would come she
would like sit up and she couldn't talk
you know she'd be like like a nurse
would be in there talking to her and she
would be like she won't be able to talk
you know you could just tell that [ __ ]
hurts so bad and once she got the
epidural she was like able to sleep she
dinner I could see these crazy
contractions on this chart and I and she
barely felt it and I could tell these
[ __ ] were huge like super
intense
I cannot imagine doing that process
without the epidural that would be that
would be unimaginably stressful and so
so difficult so I mean I I highly
endorsed that federal but you know
obviously everybody does what they think
is best you know so whatever not judging
how people give birth you know but it
was good for us it works for us the
other crazy thing is they had to give
her a catheter because she's so numb she
can't use her bladder and that ela said
that was the worst part was giving her
putting the catheter and they put the
epidural in and then they do the
catheter right afterwards but they don't
really give the epidural enough time to
come into a fact
because over the course of an hour she
became more and more numb but the
catheter was put in immediately
afterwards so if you go through the same
thing I would recommend tell them to
give you an hour come back in an hour
and then give me the catheter a catheter
is a tube that they jam up your urinary
tract into your bladder and it's not a
thin tube either let me tell you I was
shocked this tube was like [ __ ] fat
bro
it was a huge [ __ ] tube I was
like dude man I've had friends who have
had catheters up their dick hole that
sounds yeah no anything but that but I
was also cool because she didn't have
her you know the 15 hours we were you
know she had it in her she didn't she
didn't have to pee I was like that's
amazing kind of I hate pain it's like my
least favorite thing in the world
so just shove a tube up there and you're
goldie Hawn's baby so let me see I've
got all kinds of photos of her so here's
after the birth this is her horses
oh let's see these are all after the
birth yeah I could have organized it
better this better but come on ain't
good I got no time this is all the time
I got is right here I tried to work on
this more to like organize it and it was
like like what little work I put and I
was able to put into this well there's
really no work to do other than like
organizing all the photos and videos
better but either was sleeping and I had
Theodore in my lap and he was up current
all night so he was sleeping and it was
just such a relief so he was on my lap
on my chest and so the most I could do
is I had my phone in one hand you know I
wanted to work on my computer on this so
it was really hard to organize these
photos and videos on a phone but the
most I could do was like one thumb
on the phone well Theodore slept on my
sweet little guy a treasured soul all
right what where am i what am I talking
about trying to find some pictures from
oh yeah rebirth thank you dan thank you
so much god bless you so I'm a there's a
video here of super mom gets her
epidural catheter nation so let's do
super mom gets her epidural Ike these
titles yeah Here I am a super mom
absolute so this is right after she got
her epidural and they have the oxy
oxygen mask on her because I guess
Theodore's heart rate was getting kind
of erratic so they put oxygen I think
her breathing was um was strained for a
little bit because she was still feeling
pain and she was in so much discomfort
from the catheter and the epidural at
first that her breathing was strained so
you could actually see the baby's heart
rate becoming erratic because he wasn't
getting enough oxygen so they put the
mask on her to make sure the baby is
getting enough oxygen but it was I mean
it wasn't like an emergency or scary
anything it was just was all standard
procedure so we weren't worried or
anything like my hero dude the nurse
said that they've never seen anybody so
calm at this stage I've never seen
anyone this calm because she when she
came in she was five centimeters dilated
and she said the nurse said and most
people are usually screaming and pained
by them but Eva was just chilling here
like it ain't no thing this is super but
now we got her and the what do you call
it
epidural epidural you know got that
accident oxygen mask going keep it fresh
in there how's it smell in there
not great really sure can I get a hit of
that can I get that good oxygen buddy
but she's crushing it it's unbelievable
I mean the first time baby's supposed to
be like 48 hours Oh
I've been here three hours and the
nurses are saying that she's almost
ready to go
she's like fully dilated your are
[ __ ] supermom of legend and my hero
dude yeah it is true she's my hero after
going to like I'm getting there I guess
I'm getting there but you know when she
actually went into the labor and room so
once you're like fully dilated and the
doctor thinks it's time to deliver they
take you to another room a much bigger
room with everything for delivering a
baby with the tools and the machines and
then there's like a little baby warmer
station with lights and stuff for when
the baby's born and I thought I didn't I
wasn't sure what to expect you know
because me Neil we're having this debate
of like oh well should I be
should I be should I look or should I
not look at what's going on you know I
thought there would be like a separation
like I'd be able to be with ela or I'd
be able to look on the doctors side but
I thought so dude I they threw me in the
freakin trenches bro cuz elos on the
table and there was two other nurses
there and they're like they're like dad
you got to grab one of the legs and so
they removed that choice for me and it's
fine by the way because I was happy to
be involved and but I mean it was crazy
because I saw every [ __ ] thing and I
mean everything but those details are
coming next I'm getting ahead of myself
but boy I was [ __ ] it was crazy
I saw literally everything okay
damn where was I so super mom she's
amazing she really is she handled this
whole thing so incredibly we were just
chilling in that room for like hella
long watching Judge Judy dr. Phil I've
never watched either
those shows to be honest with you and
they were quite good they were quite
good
judy crushes it judge Judy's she's been
doing this a long time yeah she doesn't
take [ __ ] that's Judge Judy you know how
much she's worth her show is like so
syndicated but take you guys take a
guess without looking how much is judged
you too were Judge Judy her personally
yeah I mean probably go ahead I'm gonna
guess 40 mil okay anyone else in and
Zach I know she gets paid a lot she's
gotta head Zach I'm gonna say 200
million all righty
I have no idea make a guess play the
game 250 she's worth 420 million making
her one of the richest judges in the
world no [ __ ] I don't think judges are
supposed to make that much money it's
named another wealthy judge all [ __ ]
judge Jeff Jeff I hear my job just does
pretty well
yeah that's he's the highest-paid judge
and actually he's probably nowhere close
to her and well they're probably not
actually did I would be scared to know
of another judge making more money than
her and why yeah well she got she has so
many reruns yeah exactly she's
syndicated like every [ __ ] country
like everybody cannot get enough of
Judge Judy she's such a [ __ ] though
she's like just like there she always
does this for one person's like your
honor shut up
I'm talkin oh you still say baloney all
the time
I haven't watched her in years I guess
I'm not versed to know she that was like
her catchphrase for a while there but
it's just like small claims court
nothing's at stake yeah the show pays
the payouts that's right it shows work
yeah but it's legally binding well okay
so anyway dr. Phil is a strange show to
you guys like did you know he walks off
with his wife at the end of every
episode that tripped me out we were his
wife is in the audience in every episode
and then they join hands and walk
offstage together that's [ __ ] weird
man is super weird yeah I was like who's
that lady every episode every episode
and that seems like a bizarre detail
that I
nobody ever brings that up that's the
first I've ever heard join hands and
they walk offstage he's another guy he's
got a lot of money Phil I don't think
those as rich as Judy dr. Phil
indication doctor Oh 400 million you
rich [ __ ] holy God his feet looks like a
chipmunk kind of to be honest with y'all
look at his face it's got a face huh
yeah
entertaining stuff yeah so that was good
that past the time either was able to
sleep with the epidural I slept for a
little bit it was great that that was
when my slept up revision started
because I went to bed at like 3:00 woke
up at 5:00 and I slept maybe an hour in
that room by the time the time passed
fast honestly like we were comfortable
you know either was comfortable that's
all I cared about she was like in a good
affair I mean it's good of a mood as you
can be I mean you saw her she was act
like she wasn't incredibly good feeling
yeah so the fact that she was
comfortable and not in pain was such a
relief to me I was just I was happy you
know everything was going great so that
went on that one on until okay so I'm
getting to this point now so that went
on until about 7:00 p.m. and that's when
the doctor came in and checked her you
know cervix and was like you're fully
dilated you're ready to go her water
hadn't broken yet which is unusual at
this point so they were discussing maybe
we should make the water break where
they puncture it but then the Midwife
was like let's keep the water intact and
we'll just go into labor and let it do
its thing so we go into the delivery
room actually here I have another video
about the delivery room I'll show it to
you guys because it's pretty crazy
this is Oh catheter nation we didn't
watch that one what is this one I still
don't understand that yeah yeah it's
surreal it's absolutely [ __ ] insane
and when you either started going into
like contractions at like 1:00 a.m. last
night right now it's like 11:00 and we
came to the hospital we got arrived
about 8 a.m. and I was like oh [ __ ] dude
I got so anxious cuz it's just like
you're waiting and waiting waiting and
then but so far it's been great and it
was just absolutely crap I mean she's
just you're just amazing
dude you're my hero I was saying it was
like a silent suffer if I was on this
Minnesota right now just scream I would
be making everybody know that I'm
suffering Betty Lee's a trooper she's a
silent sufferer
shut up - all the silent sufferers up
there true yeah she's doing amazing
she's got like Ivy got the she's got a
catheter oh yeah so on the bottom there
and then that way it's really cool so
this is the baby's heart rate and then
on the bottom is the I don't know how
the hell they track the contractions
it's so interesting but like so you can
see these are pretty intense but then by
the end they were going so intense that
the line was flattening out at the top
and so she was she was starting to feel
it then but still not in pain she was
just like I can feel that I'm having a
strong contraction but like at this
point she was writhing pretty much
writhing in pain and I mean that
attitude I cannot imagine going through
that experience without the epidural
really
though the contractions so you see those
big-ass Peaks there that's every time
the ELA goes into like a contraction
which is like a eight or nine on the
pain scale [ __ ] crazy and that's the
baby's heartbeat you can kind of hear it
going put such a legend she is the
legend
all right Theodora we'll see you soon
no Punk yeah it's so weird everything
happened so fast kind of you know it's
still it's only been three days he's
three days old tonight at nine and it's
just but a boarder it takes a minute
kind of I think it's gonna take me a
couple weeks to really appreciate what
actually is going on here so at any rate
let's take a quick break here and we'll
get into the actual labor part of this
video so don't go away guys we'll be
right back clip electric toothbrush is
the toothbrush that will elevate your
brushing to the next pinnacle the apex
of oral hygiene it is a beautiful
vibrating tube with the softest bristles
in the game fastened to the front of it
it starts at just 25 bucks and you were
gonna get the quality of brush that you
will find on a $200 bs electric
toothbrush that has a battery pack the
size of my add clips got the softest
bristles in the game it's so gentle and
light it is beautiful on my gums I'm
obsessed with soft bristle heads they've
got that covered it vibrates it's got a
beautiful pulsating vibrating here and
the best part is that it times out your
brushing and it pulsates to tell you
when it's time to switch to the other
side so that you get a beautiful perfect
brush every time you brush okay and when
it's time to switch it out they'll send
you a a the top you pop off the top you
pop it back on boom it's a refill kit I
love quick because this is the best
toothbrush
pound for pound the game has ever seen
as take it from me someone who loves
brushing their teeth this is the one
you've got to try so it's why I love
quip and it's why over 1 million healthy
beautiful mouths do as well starts at
just $25 if you go to get quit dot-com
slush age 3 right now and you get your
first refill pack for free that's the
top the toothpaste for free baby let's
do this let's keep that mouth beautiful
and clean
that's your first refill pack for free
at GE t qu i p.com /h 3
hymns is a wellness brand for men and
you've heard us talking about him and
how they're helping guys look their best
you haven't yet it's time to see what
they're all about here's what we're
dealing with 66% of men start losing the
hair by age 35 and once you've noticed
thinning hair it can be too late
is that hair line slowly starting to
move backwards are any bald spots
appearing yet the best way to prevent
more hair loss is to do something about
it while you have the same freaking hair
it's time to get a handle on those
precious beautiful locks come on will
you get it I ask you do you want a bald
spot to pop up in your hair or your
hairline to recede or do you want to do
something about it first well why do you
guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing when you could turn to medicine
and science for hems comm it's a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness for men thanks to
science baldness is now optional hems is
helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and
fda-approved products to help treat
their hair loss this is not snake oil or
gas station counter supplements no this
is prescription solutions backed by
science people with a capital S hims was
created by a guy who knows some men's
health conversions are easier online
than in person because you don't have to
go to awkward and person doctor visit or
a long pharmacy line for hems connects
you with real doctors online which could
save you hours and hundreds of dollars
it's completely confidential and
discreet so order now my listeners can
get started with hims complete hair kit
for just $5 two day right out while
supplies last and subject to doctor's
approval see the website for full
details and safety information this
could cost hundreds if you went to a
doctor or pharmacy elsewhere so let's
keep those beautiful locks in your head
huh come on whoo you cannot forget about
it so go to for hanscom's /h 3 that's f
o r h IM s calm / h 3 4 hams calm / h 3
welcome back so here we are in the
delivery room so when she was ready to
go they moved us to this bigger room the
delivery room and here's a little video
to show you kind of what it looks like
ok here we go we're in the delivery room
11th hour ela is fully dilated 100%
there's a little baby head I started
getting a little emotional at this point
because when they put bring your ass in
the delivery room [ __ ] gets real because
they're setting up like instruments and
there's a little baby warmer there and
you know the thought of going into labor
is scary to anyone and I think that ela
the silent sufferer was just kind of
overwhelmed in this army not over well
but she's emotional it's like here we go
it's [ __ ] scary I mean - you know
childbirth is a serious serious [ __ ]
back in the day before modern science
like women and children used to
regularly die and childbirth because you
know it's it's a lot it's holy can go
wrong yeah even when it goes right it's
a lot right yeah you know there's a lot
of bleeding
there's cutting the way that the baby
comes out is totally crazy
there's the placenta that comes out
there's just there's it's just I mean
it's crazy dude it's a crazy crazy thing
I don't know how nature ever came how
the [ __ ] that nature come to the point
where labor was like giving birth with
something that could kill people you
know what I mean like how what the hell
kind of way to evolve is that Oh humans
are particularly terrible at it right
yes because our intelligence I guess the
baby and the mom requires so much care
and protection like the bait like a
human baby is helpless for so long of
its life compared to other animals who
can like you know fend for itself after
like months or maybe one year in a
extreme case where as the human babies
like you know in a nature setting what
fifteen it's you know sixteen seventeen
eighteen it's the intelligence because
all of the energy goes to the brain and
so to develop that the baby requires a
lot of protection so it's kind of a
trade-off luckily we have dominated this
planet we are the ultimate species and
so that's not a problem anymore but back
in the day it was definitely a big
trade-off but anyway ILA's really she's
just getting emotional understandably
but she's handling it just so gracefully
I mean she's such a legend dude she's
seriously such a legend and did what
women go through to give us children is
once you've seen it up close you got a
and then well even after she gives birth
she's got to do the breast feeding which
is honestly at times even more
challenging and stressful especially at
first it's I've heard from a lot of
women ela had trouble with the two which
I'll get into but breast feeding is a
whole nother like stressful step I think
the breast feeding itself was more
stressful in in many ways for ela the
first two days then the pregnancy itself
because being pregnant is in a way is
easy in that you don't have to do
anything it just happens and then you
can only take there's almost an
inevitability right
but breastfeeding is like if the baby
doesn't latch you can feel like a
failure if the baby is not feeding well
if the baby is crying it's like you have
to do something about you have to figure
it out but pregnancy doesn't require
anything to really figure out you just
kind of do it so in a way I think that
figuring out [ __ ] can be more stressful
and challenging mentally and painful to
breast feeding is extremely painful at
first anyway she's the best so here we
go they always go oh yeah I just put my
hand in and I tickled his head they're
always talking about how they push his
head
yeah every time they put they would
check her cervix to see how dilated is
there like I can feel his head in there
I was like what
you know his [ __ ] head is right there
you can see her huge pregnant belly was
starting to drop so she had all this
soft empty space at the top was crazy
and there's a cute little baby warmer
here yep here's all the gadgets and
everything
but he looks like continuing to be I was
calling her Xena
she's because she's a warrior princess
anyone Xena princess warrior princess oh
yeah right got a dick ulis and then here
look do you door so it's just a quick
little update but any any words before
showtime
of course it's the big deal and I was
noticing how all the nurses around here
it's so routine for them and so
extraordinary for us yeah
they delivered three other babies
already today it's just like poo poo poo
poo
it's amazing there's just such a strange
job they have okay
well we'll see you guys next time with
the baby okay and so also this is like
the end of a super long day the
anticipation of this moment and so when
it finally comes to be there's a lot of
excitement and nervousness and emotions
so anyway she's here the nurse comes in
at about I'll say 8:00 and then we start
pushing you know it's just hurt the the
midwife a nurse and it was just me in
there and there and the Midwife was like
go ahead and grab your wife's leg
the nurses are gonna grab the other one
and I'm gonna you know you know hut hut
hike whatever I'm gonna be quarterback
so I didn't have a choice because me
neither kept talking like I'm gonna
either you know ela didn't want me to
look she really didn't even want me to
see what was going on down there so I
thought I was just gonna be by her you
know like okay you got you know no I was
in that [ __ ] so I had her leg and the
nurse I was like and I mean I can see
everything now let me say this first of
all because first I mean for me it
wasn't that bad and that like I've seen
it was like passing out and gagging I
mean everyone's different but for me I
thought I was glad I got to see it
because it was it was a
it was crazy I mean ela was the one
experiencing it so the least I could do
is [ __ ] see it but and so anyway I
was holding her leg up so when she
pushed basically I was bracing her leg
like the other nurse but these nurses
are so amazing they're they're
incredible they're like so encouraging
so when she pushes it's it's so hard
it's so tough like when she was pushing
I felt like I was pushing because it's
like posh so you time it with the
contractions and so it's like you wait
wait and then when you see a
contractions coming the nurse is like
all right posh come on one more you got
it it's like they make her push for 10
seconds so it's like one one nurse
counts to ten and then the others like
you got it come on push and I'm holding
it I'm like I'm pushing it's intense
dude she's got her leg she's hope she's
bracing her legs like you know this and
she's pushing and like it's about that
goes on for about an hour and so
eventually oh so her water broke by the
way when she started pushing and it was
[ __ ] crazy it was like I have a movie
like there nurse was sitting there and
she got like it was splash zone it came
like was wild you don't some things are
like they are in the movies and some
things art I mean in this case it was
like a splash zone it was a crazy thing
I mean we were all laughing cuz it was
it was wild the mood was fantastic in
there though because the nurses were
just so upbeat and caring and positive
and encouraging it was almost smiles you
know up until the last moment which was
like [ __ ] intense so she's pushing
she's pushing and then all of a sudden
you could first of all see ass attitude
so it was [ __ ] crazy so the nurse she
was pushing and the nurse I mean it's
huge like again
it's not like the vagina is being
blasted open like the body is expanding
itself that's what all these muscle
contractions are is that it's dilating
it by 10 centimeters which is a lot so
the opening gets quite quite enlarged
and the nurse is she's like jamming her
whole hand in there and like so the
baby's head is starting to come out and
the nurse is like kind of making space
and they're pouring like bottles of Lube
in there to prevent tearing I guess
lacerations and so they keep pouring
like mint like bottles of mineral oil
over the baby's head and the baby starts
coming out and you can see the tip of
his head he's got a hairy he's got a lot
of black like jet-black hair and the top
of his head looks like a freaking
meatball like it looks like a meatball I
was thinking in my head like I'm gonna
call him meatball I've been calling him
meatballs like don't tell him why I
could tell him that call him that but
his head looked like a damn matzo ball
with black hair it was crazy
I was like whoa so she's pushing and his
head is coming out more and more and
more and eventually she's pushing over
the course of an hour pushing pushing
pushing and then once basically she's
pushing so hard and so for so long you
can tell it's such difficult work and
eventually the head is just there's a
point where the head is really just
crowning how you know it's just the tip
so she calls in all the doctors she
calls in like a pediatrician she calls
in a lung doctor she calls on all these
doctors too so when the baby's born they
immediately put him on the little baby
thing and check his vitals and make sure
he's healthy and everything so all of a
sudden right before it happens there's
like five more people to come in the
room it was like a ton of people there
so it's like push push push push push
push push first you know
push push push push push push push she's
killing herself she's just trying so
hard and it feels like it's not
happening but the nurses are super
encouraging and it's just like push push
push push push
and then the Midwife is like I might
have to make a cut there's an episiotomy
they call it when they cut the vagina
open a little wider to calm it but she's
like I'm gonna try not to do that and so
in the end she didn't have to do it
because eel is such a warrior so the
head pops out completely they pull the
head out I guess the the hardest part is
clearing the head past like the pelvic
bone once you do that it's home it's
basically just pops right out
so she clears the head out and this to
me was the craziest moment and I didn't
see it because she you know I was I had
the front-row seat he look couldn't see
anything the head pops out and he's huge
by the way he's 9 pounds
he's [ __ ] enormous and when I when I
saw him that my first thought was how
the [ __ ] did that thing come out of her
he's huge he's tall I mean he's tall you
know and his shoulders were so broad I
think more broad than most babies
because when when the Midwife pulled him
out his shoulders actually did end up
shredder come give me a break huh who
you kidding what come on he's wrong good
boy so his shoulders did end up tearing
her and she did have to get stitches but
it seems minor you know the stitches
dissolve and she doesn't need to do any
[Music]
special anything for it so it's fine but
so the head is popped out all you see is
the head and so what what the Midwife
does is she puts her hand on either side
of the head and she literally just pulls
him out she like pulls and Swiss
sym out and his body shredder you
ruining helmet so she pulls the body out
by the head so she puts either hands on
the side of the head and she's gotta
yank pretty hard cuz his body stretches
like a piece of gum um it was so crazy
this was the craziest thing I saw the
whole day she pulls his whole [ __ ]
body out stretches his head and his neck
is just being it looks like in the bay
he looks like she's gonna kill him but I
mean that's the way it's done that's how
they do it ever with every baby cuz his
neck is just so she took him out he came
out this huge [ __ ] baby and the
umbilical cord is crazy I didn't expect
it it's huge gnarly looking thing it's
like a huge tube with all of these crazy
veins and [ __ ] and they take the baby
and they immediately give it to ela so
she can see and ela standards
they put him on ela she's crying in
hysterical and he just starts peeing
everywhere and so we all started
laughing cuz me neither were looking at
each other and laughing because Theodore
was literally peeing everywhere all
right shredder
are you kidding shredder and she's just
I'm hysterical
I'm looking at ela because I'm just
worried about her but she's crying she's
happy she's hysterical
I'm starting I'm tearing I'm looking
it's just waterworks I'm crying I'm
laughing I'm smiling I'm worried at all
at the same time so they get they put
the baby on ela they clamped the
umbilical cord ela sitting there with
the baby
you know he he immediately latched on to
her breasts which was amazing
and they clamped the umbilical cord they
having me cut it I'm taking pictures
here I've got a bunch of pictures I'll
show you after this description and then
they bring him over to that little baby
station you saw on there checking of his
vitals and he's crying you know he's
going ballistic he doesn't know what's
going on hold on one sec you know you
can only imagine how traumatic traumatic
no wonder we're all [ __ ] up the moment
of Inception in this earth is the most
traumatic thing ever you come out of
this warm safe place and it's just
there's bright lights I could see him
trying to open his eyes and there's this
really bright light on him so the
doctors can see but I can see like ah
the light was just [ __ ] his eyes up
you know and I can see that he doesn't
like bright lights still from I don't
know I just really recall his eyes and
just being blinded and so they cut the
umbilical cord they clamp it they're
checking him there you know wiping him
off cuz he's covered in blood and
whatever embryonic fluid which his lungs
are full of embryonic fluid for the
first several hours to which so he's
caught always caught he's kind of like
drowning in a way almost in his own logs
and coughing up all this fluid and then
they they give the baby back to ela once
he's all clean and checked out and he's
healthy thank god you're so worried you
know I just I was following the Jimmy
Kimmel thing because he recently had a
son who came out with like this terrible
heart disease and they have to
immediately perform open-heart surgery
on a newborn baby Wow and so you know
there's just there's a million things
going through your head and most of all
you're just praying for everyone to be
healthy and fine and he was and I was
just very relieved when they're like
he's fine everyone's fine he was fine
the mid work the Midwife is meanwhile
stitching up EULA oh yeah there was
actually before that she delivered the
placenta so what's left of the umbilical
cord
she pulled it's connected to the
placenta and it's [ __ ] huge she's
pulling the biblical cord out of her
vagina and then attached to it comes
this huge placenta dude it I mean it is
an organ literally but it looks like an
organ it looks like aw you know if you
just took out my liver or heart or
something it just looks like an organ
it's just been pulled out of her vagina
it was this huge crazy-looking thing
anyway so they're stitching her up and
the baby's fine and they give her the
baby and she's just she's crying like
tears of joy like I mean just
unbelievable and I'm not I'm not a
picture taker that by any means I have
no almost no pictures of anything but
and I've been taking a lot of pictures
and it's been I've been loving love love
loving it taking the photos of course I
closed the document with the photos so
let me open it but I just started
snapping photos because I thought man I
got a I need you need anything need
photos of this and I just I look at them
all the time now like they're just
they're amazing let me open this up so
the pictures kind of tell the story here
so so this was basically right after I
mean he was all these pictures are
immediately after birth that I'm about
to show you I mean like one or two
minutes after he he came into this world
and so this is after they clipped the
cord you can see they have it clamped
here and they brought him over and
weighed him so so this is like I mean a
minute after he was born
you can see his weight why is it doing
that it's distorting the photo I try to
zoom in yeah so there he is he's just
the newborn baby they're so [ __ ]
fragile and they're so scared and and
pain and suffering and confused but it's
just surreal to see this little guy so
here she is so this is this is before
that photo actually this is literally
the second after and these photos are so
powerful in my opinion those tears of
joy and the expression on her face with
the baby there I mean it's just it's
like all inspiring you know he's got a
little beanie on he was just like what
the [ __ ]
so this is after they wait I'm on the
other side now and I can see his face I
feel like he's already grown in three
days I know it's weird but he already
looks different he already looks more
like human yeah just look at this I mean
it says it all for me this is like such
a powerful photo I mean God the photo
could say I can say more than words
right
this is the one I posted and dude can
you can we appreciate how beautiful
Allah is this is directly after giving
birth and Theodore's hand all of his
limbs are blue because the blood goes to
like the vital organs so as his hands
and his legs aren't being oxygenated yet
so they look like blue and lifeless but
they get colors very shortly I mean dude
Allah is killing it look at this Xena
Warrior Princess over here such amazing
so amazing so this kind of give you a
longer view of what's going on here
she was attempting to breastfeed and
actually he latched right on which was
amazing it's incredible the instincts
like I mean he's just born and he knows
to suck something in this was this was
when we were moved to so once you're
done with delivery and everything's good
after about two hours they moved us to
basically just a room a hospital room
where you can be with the baby we were
in this room for two days breastfeeding
and the doctors were coming and checking
his vitals and you know all the all the
doctor [ __ ] and this was the first night
he's got okay you know they put a LoJack
they put a tracking device on newborn
baby's legs so that no one else can
remove the baby but you it's good but I
was like what the hell you know the baby
war is so well protected like the doors
are locked and sealed and they have to
buzz you in
it's like a jewelry store you know I
don't know who these [ __ ] psychos are
stealing babies but apparently enough
babies were stolen or mixed up you know
you hear [ __ ] like that yeah I've heard
the stories
so so actually what was so awesome about
kaiser is that the baby never ever
leaves your your side the baby is with
you at all times they never ever take it
away from you so like in the delivery
room the station is there and then in
the hospital room there's a what do you
call it Adam anyway there's a little
baby bed there and you're with the baby
all the time and it's great I love that
so this is the critter yeah he's it's
funny because he's I feel like he's
already looking more he's already
looking different
it's really something there's this that
day one like the fresh out out of the
womb baby is just so frail and so
delicate and even in a short two days
he's already kind of like his skin is is
warmer and his features are more defined
and it's crazy this is so cute
this I think was probably oh my god
isn't he so cute so you can see this is
kind of what I'm talking about this was
like more before we went home and you
can see his face is kind of already like
shape and up a little bit
God he saw his face he's just such a
precious little guy look at that give me
a break on who you kiddin who you kid
not look at this so cute this is in the
hospital room and when he sleeps it's
like the best thing ever
he's just so sweet and you feel so proud
because he's just crying and you're
checking his diaper and you're trying to
burp him or he's hungry you're trying to
breastfeed but when he falls asleep it's
like you did everything right you know
it's like a puzzle every time he cries
and so when he falls asleep it's like
level completed but also he's just so
sweet and
you know you can really enjoy the moment
of like having the baby because you're
not all stressed out trying to figure
out what what he what he needs it's just
it's amazing like last night he slept
with me for four hours and it's just
like the sweetest thing he loves it you
know it's funny how I see it because we
would take ultrasounds of Theodore and
he had his hand by his head in the
ultrasounds and we noticed that he loves
putting his hand by his head now and it
comforts it huh
but really they love being wrapped up
tight because in the womb they're
they're so tight up in there and it's
just funny because we even as adults
love being wrapped up or being tucked in
or you know having weighted blankets and
it you can see it's just it all goes
back to the [ __ ] womb dude cuz
Theodore like when he when I'm trying to
comfort him he loves when I take his
arms in his hands and just like press it
press it against his body and kind of
just Nussle him you know but with
newborns you do this thing where you
wrap the blanket tightly around them so
they feel like they're in the womb you
know they love that but when he's
sleeping it's just that's the sweetest
thing ever so amazing
this is ela loving that he's sleeping
why is this one not loaded cute cute
cute cute look it so this is what I'm
talking about the bassinet is what is
called cute s this was my proud dad
moment where ela needed to sleep and I
was staying up and watching Theodore and
I got him to sleep and this was my proud
dad moment with both of them sleeping
for the first time little do you know
that he started crying hysterically 1
minute later but the picture itself
doesn't matter
exactly I got the picture and then this
was the cutest [ __ ] ever yeah so they
say the baby's not supposed to sleep
with you because if you fall asleep and
he rolls over it can be dangerous to the
baby but I was staying up with them so I
said go to sleep and I'll watch and make
sure he's fine so either was able to
fall asleep with Theodore and cuddle
with him and which you're not supposed
to do but I was washing so I was fine
and it was just the sweetest [ __ ] ever
like they fell asleep like this was so
[ __ ] amazing
look at this [ __ ] I was just oh my God
look at him with his little hand like
I'm gonna beanie his little hand [ __ ] so
amazing this picture so freakin kid look
at her shoulder what's going on here
it's just an angle good so look at this
I love the two of them like that so cute
it's hard why did I take the photos
lengthwise with my stupid um it's hard
to imagine the hope that he's just
sleeping in her arms and it's just it's
just ridiculous come on who you kiddin
uh forget about it raw he's the Ross of
the raw is yeah I took a lot of pictures
of this I was just loving look at this
come on come on
he's like a little giver and Hebrew
Gever means guy so I say the Lord ever
and he but you could say like hey give
her what a guy
like it means the same thing in English
what a guy you know like so he's a giver
his little arm oh so then this was the
breakfast I was just like what [ __ ] and
ela had this unbelievable craving for
meat and the hospital food was so bad
there was a McDonald's really close to
the hospital ela ate a [ __ ] quarter
pounder with cheese three days in a row
whoa what I was like McDonald's she she
wanted McDonald's that's all she wanted
that is very out of character she briefs
noted a quarter-pound she's craving meat
I don't know she wants me to cook steak
tonight so she's low in iron the doctor
yeah it's kind of a weird an interesting
thing that her body is at the same time
craving me I can't get over this thing
that's truly nasty I wouldn't have ever
guessed that that was eggs I didn't
either until I tasted it because I
picked it up it's super heavy and I'm
man it's like a brick of egg okay so so
then the other question was like how did
shredder do so that's kind of the next
part the epilogue of the story if you
will so I captured let me find this
video so we watched this one oh there's
the this kind of just to show you they
gave him a bath of warm water this was
his first bath and only bath probably
bathe him tonight
[Music]
nice and warm nice and warm his lip
Twitter's when he gets really oh it's
just like poor guy but he chills right
away once he's comfortable he can go
from like a hundred to zero like
instantly right yeah pretty much it's
hard the thing about like raising a
newborn baby I think that's important to
remember it's not to panic because just
because he's a sterically crying don't
let it you know panic you you got to
take your time sometimes and and do the
job right because just because he's
panicking and going hysterical doesn't
mean that he's not fine and the moment
you get him wrapped up and finished
he's like perfectly happy again so he's
only got that one note right you know
well he's done he has it he's got like a
differs a there's a scale it's a stay
love yeah there's a scale of hysteria
for sure that that's like maxed out what
you just saw right so we've got shredder
meets Theodore
so we long suspected that shredder knew
he Louis pregnant because as she was
progressing through pregnancy he became
more and more defensive over at times
even barking at me when I would approach
the bed at night you know yeah so here
we go here he is meeting Theodore for
the first time
[Music]
right he hadn't seen her in a few days
at this point man yeah he was with my
parents for two days we literally just
got home so so he was very eager say I
and here actually here's a part two here
my mom of course didn't push the record
button as I expected perfect oh that's
the cutest [ __ ] I've ever seen
[Laughter]
dogs are so good with babies dude so
okay this was his first moment when he
was super excited but let me show you
these photos because he has been so
sweet like he has not left the baby side
since since we got home and when
Theodore cries like he gets so worried
and he just wants to help and he starts
like licking his feet and stuff like
like for example this is how he was
laying last night yeah that's he's
literally cuddled with Theodore on
heelas lap and he just won't leave her
side it's the cutest [ __ ] it's so
precious do you see this dead like lying
parallel I mean I'm just I'm so proud of
a little shred this is how they were
sleeping last night shredders walking
over come on oh you guys this is how
Theodore was sleeping in my lap last
night look at this this is me last night
till [ __ ] 4:00 a.m. when L woke up
and took over and then she woke me up at
7:00 a.m. - Theodore at a freaking 10
chaos scale had a crazy huge poop she
needed my help changing and she
definitely that those poops those
newborn poops are so crazy it's like
black tar
because ILA's not lactating it you don't
you get you'll probably get her milk in
today so he has like natural reserves in
his body that he's consuming and the
poop that expresses is like black tar
yes it's and it's sticky and
unbelievable and it was a huge one this
morning so that was my my my wake up
this was a proud dad moment baby
shredder mom boom whoo you kid
oh this was the first moment I held him
this was in the delivery room
I was rocked it was like a rocking chair
and he fell asleep and it was very very
uncredible well he looked so cute there
there's the guy we gave him the pacifier
at first because he was latching well
but then because he was starting to have
trouble latching we took the pacifier
away because you don't want him to get
used to the pacifier or you start to
prefer it because he loves that thing
man like you put it in him he's happy as
a clam but if he becomes dependent on it
it can cause trouble with ELA latching
and that's the ultimate worst thing you
don't wanna do that so we're gonna hope
we're trying to hold off on the pacifier
until the feeding gets down cute cute so
cute his face is just so cute little one
teeth cool beanie looking pretty dope
there look at that
God look at him that's how they love it
he's wrapped up like a frickin mummy
he's like looks like a mummified baby
but he loves that that's his most
peaceful state so I think that I think
that's everything
I think that's every everything that
covers it let me see what else I got
here oh I want to say for the record
that Allah did not [ __ ] herself hey I
know we had spoken a lot about that we
expressed concerns about that okay
that's all right she did not poop
herself so just going on the record and
saying here overall the experience for
us was really was really a positive one
it wasn't really it wasn't really that
bad it was really intense and scary
during the point of labor just because
it's so nerve-wracking but overall it
was a really great experience and I
think
the faculty at Kaiser Permanente made it
a lot better made it so good
it was incredible I would have if we
have more babies I'll have it there
without hesitation unbelievable so
amazing but overall it was a fantastic
experience and I'm just so grateful to
ela for being supermom and for
everything she's gone through you know
did she I don't know what it's just
nature listen I tell her all the time
listen if I could trade places with you
it's so easy to say you know I would
totally trade places with you I joke
with her about it listen if I could I
would know but for whatever reason
Nature [ __ ] over not [ __ ] over let's
say nature charged our females with this
sacred duty so so we have to cherish
that sacred duty and so and Father's Day
is coming up I get my first Father's Day
man that's right couple weeks right
people keep asking me if I want to do
anything for Father's Day it's like bro
first of all I've been a dad for like
three days so I think it's a little
presumptuous tour to be celebrating
fathers day and and then second of all
what better you know a way to celebrate
I'm just want to be at home with the
family dude that's Father's Day shi-it
yeah let's go celebrate Father's Day
let's go to the part and leave yeah mom
and the baby no it's a family damn well
that's about it I don't really plan on
talking about anything more today I just
wanted to keep it you know to the point
keep it short and get back home to the
Bubba and ELA yeah I got to go get
groceries and cook some steak fur she's
craving filet mignon so you know you
boys got to do it so um but you're
feeling pretty good about that we're
gonna eat mashed potatoes
we're gonna need filet mignon and
broccoli that's the that's the dream
meal
go ahead what is it it's raw do I have
that one you've got one that's on the
Rost of the raw
it's a cur hit him with the wrost of the
bra I know maybe just the regular oh hey
yo come on
do we have raw yeah that's the one and
only on no introduction for you
slam on them with the regular smiler all
right I guess we don't have the Ross of
the raw we'll line up the raw for next
time mm-hmm yeah all right well you know
that's about it I'll be back you know I
gotta come I got to bring it to you guys
the Rost every week up you know I'll be
back next Friday probably by myself
doing a more regular episode but I'm
keeping them brief just so I can get
back to the family but happy to share
with you guys and happy to share it
while it's still fresh in my mind
and I've got all these beautiful
wonderful pictures and videos to draw
from to really pull from from memory but
overall the experience has been so
surreal you know you got this baby it's
only been three days and like I said
it's gonna take me it's gonna take me
some time to really realize what we're
dealing with but for now it's just my
focus on supporting ELA making sure
she's got everything she needs and she's
comfortable and taking care of the baby
so she can sleep after he feeds I try to
put him to sleep so she can sleep and
that's you know that's gonna we're
pretty much taking time off right now so
we're gonna be well-deserved yeah we'll
probably be away I'm just gonna I'm
gonna pop in here on Fridays and do the
show I have another video that like
basically is 90% done when ela started
going into labor so I'm probably gonna
finish that this weekend and just pop it
up there and then and then take a break
for first several weeks at least but I
hope you guys enjoyed I mean the support
we've gotten we received was just
incredible
I'm happy to
see babies are this just miracle like
they bring so much joy into the world
you know like just exiting the hallway
or exiting the hospital going to the car
to bring Theodore home you know I
thought walking around with shredder was
crazy
with how everyone's like obsessed
without cute but when we were there with
Theodore everyone like literally
everyone was just like all
congratulations yeah you know because
there's a lot of traffic at the Kaiser
center and it was just like we won a
competition or something
people were practically just clapping
everyone stopped what they were doing
just started clapping you know man when
we walk around with Theodore and
shredder it's gonna be crazy I'm like
pulling my eyebrow hairs out sorry I was
like over super long one here right now
I'm trying to yank out but he's amazed I
mean he's amazing you know the first
week has got to be the toughest the
hardest night first was probably the
first night in the hospital room because
it's like it's so scary you're alone
with the baby you don't know what to do
you're trying to breastfeed it's really
hard it's really painful for Yili doubt
that was such a long night I mean we
didn't sleep at all he looked a little
bit and I stayed watch he's supposed to
be sleeping like 16 hours a day but he's
just been crying a lot so he's been
under slept and then I think
overstimulated which makes it harder for
him to sleep so I mean it's been tough
it's been challenging but it's been
beautiful and it's going to get easier
over the next couple of weeks I'm sure
but what can you say you know it's a
crazy thing epidural get the epidural
that's my advice to expecting mothers
really big come away yeah absolutely and
that's about it I'm a dad now so a big
papa I got to deal with some of us I
gotta go deal with some [ __ ] now all
right fish
well that's it guys I hope you enjoyed
thank you for the well wishes and the
you know all the beautiful all the nice
words and all the support and all the
kindness I mean you guys credible
gracious beautiful thank you so much for
sharing this joy with us I'm I'm
thrilled I mean the fact that I've got a
healthy baby boy I've got a healthy baby
mom who will handle it beautifully
that's the biggest blessing in the world
you know that's the Father's Day gift
that any of us could ask for so scary
that you know something could happen but
he was fine
god bless I'm so sleeping my eyes are
starting to close let's get you out of
here then don't wake up call alright so
I'll see you next week guys and I guess
stay tuned this weekend for a new vid
which is gonna be just I'm out I'm gonna
do it and I'm out I'm have to sneak in
when Theodore sleeping I've got like an
hour of editing left seriously just have
to put music in it's a good video too I
think you guys will enjoy it can't wait
forget about it huh forget about it so
we'll see you next Friday guys thank you
all love you appreciate you Tata for now
see you then
[Music]